you know what struck me the most
honestly was when I took a minute to
actually talk to some of the Muslim
people to find out you know they are
just like me and I am uneducated on
their religion you know I could easily
make as many mistakes judgment calls as
any other person out there but when I
took a second to sit down and listen to
them and actually enter their mosque in
going and watch some of their prayers it
was a beautiful thing and they answered
some of my questions that I had and I
just feel that maybe that that's
something that they should do too for
the people a lot a lot of us were
uneducated you know educate us on your
religion let us know that not
everybody's a bad bad person amazing the
human connection look he went into the
mosque he saw it wasn't about making
factory and he's calling he's called it
he's a he's a made he said educate us on
your religion what are your thoughts on
us I mean it's it's exactly an example
of what I was just talking about that
there are many people who we may deem
Islamophobic at first glance at first
instance because of the rhetoric that
they engage in and oftentimes it's
similar to the one from the maliciously
intended
you know Islamophobic organized network
but we need to go back and analyze
difference between the majority of
Americans who may exhibit Islamophobic
rhetoric but just don't know any better
and our fair game for engagement and can
potentially change a man like this and
those who are agenda driven and sort of
rooted in hate and bigotry and we needs
to have different strategies we can't
have a one size fit all for the you know
sort of dyed-in-the-wool Islamic opes we
expose we deconstruct and we engage in
refutations of their lives with
individuals like this and many Americans
who are like him we engage in education
in awareness building in shedding light
on the reality of Islam and Muslims